hi I'm Jordan design and I'm a scientist
here at Thermo Fisher Scientific and
we're doing a live training today on
neural induction using our neural
induction media from human pluripotent
stem cells to neural stem cells and then
subsequently we're gonna do a neuronal
differentiation using our 327 and B 27
plus neuronal culture systems so let's
get started the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to do neural
induction using our neural induction
media so we have a starting cell type
over here on the evos so if we look at
this image on the evos this is our
starting PSCs they're about 70 to 90
percent confluent what that means is
that you see they're pretty much
touching the colonies are touching each
other but they're also very clean so
this is a feeder free culture without
spontaneous differentiation that's key
because if you have not a not-so-clean
culture sometimes the neural induction
won't won't be as specific and you'll
get some contaminating non-neuronal
cells hypes at the end so you just want
to make sure to have that clear culture
throughout and there's no
differentiating stem cells in there so
the first step on neuronal culture is
actually day one or day 0 you're going
to replate your PSC culture back into
the same matrix that you started with so
for example I have mine in stem flux and
gel tracks so I'm just going to replate
in stem tet and simplex and gel tracks
again at 300k per 6-well plate so I have
this right here so the next day which
would be day one you want about a
culture that's gonna be about 15 to 25
percent confluent that's the range and
it looks like we've got this here so day
one
after you have replated your PSCs you're
actually going to change
into your neural induction media and our
neural induction media is basically just
our neural induction supplement plus our
neuro basal media so once we change our
media with that you're gonna change the
media to mils per well on that day one
and then you're also gonna change the
media day to day four and day six and
actually a day seven you should have
your your full neuronal stem cell
population so I actually have an example
right here for you guys if we go back on
the Evo's you guys can see that these
are day seven induced at neural stem
cells so they're very very concentrated
and dense it's a good sign because
neural stem cells are quite small so
they'll kind of clump on top of each
other to you'll see like this
mountainous structure but we don't want
to see is is more spread out larger cell
types in this that could mean that you
have some neural non-neuronal cells but
here this looks like it's a pretty
consistent dense population which is
what exactly what we want so once you
have your your day seven that we make
those neural stem cells p0 you want to
replate so we'll actually just replay it
with a cute ace and I'll give you an
example of how they should look once
they're replated so if we go back on the
evos these are some good replated neural
stem cells right here so we usually play
a million per six well which is what
we've got right here and they're they're
smaller and they're quite dense as well
and you can already see that some of the
these cell types have little extending
prophecies which is what we want so
these will actually get confluent around
four to six days after you play at this
one million per well sometimes if you
start with a really nice PSC culture
they'll actually proliferate a lot
faster so you can even get a full NS C
dense well front by around two to three
days and
what I mean by that is it could range
anywhere from 10 million to 20 millions
even 30 million per well of a 6-well
plate so if you're anywhere in that
target range that's good that means
you've got some some great neural
induction in your NS ease so now that
we've talked about neural induction a
little bit and how to get our NFC's from
our pluripotent stem cell cultures we're
gonna dive in and we're gonna do a
neuronal differentiation so the first
step in neuronal differentiation is
you're going to take your already dense
culture of your your NSC so say I just
the ones I just showed you go about four
to six days till they're confluent and
ready to passage at this point you can
either freeze them down and create a
bank of NFC's or you can put them in
maturation media which is what we're
gonna do right now so the first step is
we're going to wash with PBS - - so
that's - calcium - magnesium so we're
gonna make sure that we are gonna
aspirate off that spent medium
[Applause]
and then you're going to add a 1 mil per
six well of your PBS - -
[Applause]
and then we are going to aspirate that
off again
[Music]
and then now we're going to add one mill
of our stem Pro a cuties cell
dissociation reagent so we actually use
stem Pro a cute ace because we want to
singular eyes the cells so once we add
the Accu taste on
[Applause]
this is actually going to go in the
incubator and incubate at 37 degrees for
about five to eight minutes
[Applause]
so I have a cell well right here that I
already previously Accu taste and if you
guys come over to the Evo it's real
quick you can see they are all pretty
singular eyes and they're floating
around now so they're no longer attached
to the well if you still find that your
cells are attached because of starting
of really dense and SC culture you can
also use a cell scraper to scrape off
the rest but this looks pretty good so
now from here we're gonna add one mill
of our PBS - - to our well to inactivate
the enzyme
[Applause]
and then you meet you want to make sure
you just kind of go around the welds get
all the spell clumps off if you're not
going to use a cell scraper and then
we're going to transfer all this to a 15
mil carnival
[Applause]
and then we're also going to add an
additional 5 to 10 mils so I'm gonna add
5 mils
[Applause]
just to make sure that enzyme is
deactivated and we can get a nice wash
of PBS - - so once we add all those
we're actually gonna spin ourselves down
right now so our cells are gonna spin at
300 times G for five minutes so while
that's spinning down this is a good time
to talk about our be 27 and B 27 +
neuronal culture systems and how they
differ so classically people have been
using our 327 culture systems for more
than 25 years for their in vitro
neuronal studies we just developed this
B 27 + culture system which is about a
year old and there's actually quite a
bit of advantages to the system over B
27 some of those advantages include
improved neuronal survival so you can
get more than 50% survival of your
neurons versus culture 1 I mean not
culture 1a b27 classic and then also
there's accelerated neuro outgrowth we
also see a lot of better electrical
activity in these B 27 plus media
systems versus b27 and other competitors
out there so what I mean by that is we
see more neuronal network activity more
firing more coverage this is this is
over multi-electrode array studies so
more coverage over the electrodes in the
well so all these things combined show
that we have improved neuronal maturity
in RB 27 plus systems which is a very
neat thing to see because we can get
faster results and quicker results for
our studies so we don't have to wait as
long for our neurons to richer as I'm
sure I'm sure most of you who do in
vitro studies out there typically wait
weeks and months for those neurons to be
mature enough to run these in vitro
assays another thing I'd like to mention
is our culture one supplement so I'm
actually going to use this today as well
so our culture one supplement is a
really cool supplement that is designed
to eliminate the
neuronal cells in our neuronal stem
cells in neuronal maturation so commonly
if you play your NSCs for maturation
sometimes you get a extending
proliferation of those neuronal stem
cells in the culture which results in
clumping of the neurons at the end of at
the end of your time point so we have
developed culture one which eliminates
that neural stem cell growth so that
those mature neurons are the only ones
in the media and you have those you
eliminate those non-neuronal
contaminating cell types so you guys
will see later today a couple images
using our culture one and how it's
actually great especially if you want to
do some endpoint imaging assays that way
you can see you can select individual
neurons which is really good for like
haiku quit screening and Hydra put
assays so the last thing I want to
mention is how you make the media so
there's two different ways to make so
there be 27 classic is simple it's just
our neuro basal media and then our b27
supplement you can also add our 1x
culture one which I was just talking
about and then we have 1x glutimax
supplement and then 200 milli molar
ascorbic acid so it's quite easy just
five ingredients or four ingredients if
you don't want to put culture 1 to make
your media and then 4 be 27 plus media
it's the same media formulation but
instead of the instead of neuro Basel
you're gonna use neuro Basel Plus and
then instead of b27 supplement you're
gonna use be 27 plus so those are the
two differences between the two media's
however for the purposes today we
actually recommend that if you want to
use the be 27 plus media system you
start out culturing in in be 27 for
about three to seven days and then
transfer over to our be 27 plus media
sis
so we're gonna do that today for you
guys and it looks like our cells are
done so once we have our pelleted cells
the next step would be to ask right off
[Applause]
so we just have our cell pellet it down
below and then we're going to actually
resuspend in either 1 or 2 mils of our
maturation media depending on how many
cells we have so I'm just going to use 1
mil right now
make sure you pipette up and down so
that those cells are still singular eyes
and evenly distributed in this media and
then we're actually going to count
ourselves so we have our countess - I'm
going to use so we haven't actually have
these pre-made countess - slides so I'm
just going to rip it out of the package
and then I'm going to take 10
microliters of our cell suspension
[Applause]
and add it to ten microliters a trypan
blue so trypan blue permeates the
membrane of dead cells being able to
give us a live cell stain and a dead
cell stain so once I pipette this up up
and down nicely we're going to take ten
microliters of that and insert it into
the slide
[Applause]
and right here you guys can see it's
inserted nicely into the slide so I'm
going to walk over here to the countess
too and insert our slide in
oh one second insert slide you're just
gonna follow the prompts it's actually
going to auto focus for you which it's
doing right now if it doesn't auto focus
for you it has a nice little manual
focus over here and then also manual
zoom so you have those two options if
your cell type isn't focused as well so
right here it looks like it's focused
you press capture and it's automatically
gonna count based off of the trypan blue
so it's going to give us a total account
and then a live count and a dead count
which you can see right here so it's
about 84 percent live 16 percent dead so
not too bad so once we do that and we
get our lifestyle count we can go over
here and then play our neurons
[Applause]
so I have an already coated poly G
lysine and double coated mouse laminin
plate so that's 50 micrograms per
milliliters of Paulie G laminin and then
three micrograms per mil of mouse
laminate so you're gonna double coat
those and then once I have my double
coating I'm going to count the
appropriate amount of cells so for p27
and culture one supplementally
recommends about four times ten to the
four per per cell or per centimeter
squared so four times ten to the four
cells per centimeter squared which
equates to about a million cells per per
6-well plate so per one well over six
well so I'm actually going to aspirate
off this mouse laminin
[Applause]
and then
I'm gonna get another at the Dorf tube
and take my 1 million cells from my
resuspension
[Applause]
add an additional mil of media
so I've got one mill of our cells in our
media and then a typical amount of media
for a six well as to Mills so I'm going
to add another media or another mill of
our b27 classic media and then now I can
add my cell suspension you never want to
add cells directly to the well without
media already in it so that's why I
already put some media in the well for
you guys
perfect so once those are added these
can actually go in the incubator
[Applause]
and you can start the neuronal
maturation process so we actually
observe maturation markers using RB 27
plus B 27 and B 27 plus media systems
even after three days in culture once
you plate for maturation today I
actually have an example of a day 10 so
if we go over to the evos gonna have to
go to 10x to see this
and brighten that up a little bit
so these are our day 10 neurons in b27
and culture 1 media and then a date 5 we
transferred over to be 27 plus so 5 days
and be 27 5 days and be 27 plus you guys
can see that it's a nice mono layer
there's minimal cell clumping you also
see very elongated axons and they're
very connected it's a nice culture
especially for imaging purposes and then
also after you do your right field
photos to get some you want to do some
QC which is a good thing to do when
you're making neurons for the first time
so I actually have a PowerPoint slide to
show you guys right now of our neuronal
QC so that this slide right here on the
left hand side we are showing our same
same neuronal culture stained with
synaptic Eisen and not - and those are
two commonly used neural markers I'm
sure you guys are aware and then on the
right hand side we have beta through
tubulin or 2jh one which is also a
common neuronal marker so you guys can
see that they're very mature at day 10
it's a very homogeneous population of
neurons so there's not a lot of neuronal
glio everything stains everything that
is stained seems to be neuronal and
that's the work of our culture 1 and B
27 plus system so after the slide which
looks like we're done that is the end of
our live training on neuronal
differentiation using our be 27 and B 27
plus culture systems all be are you
ready to take any questions you guys may
have
[Applause]
all right Thank You Jordan it was a very
nice demonstration of how we can make
neurons out of induced pluripotent stem
cells so we received a number of
questions around the process starting
from IPSC all the way to neurons so
could you speak a little bit more about
the the use of b27
in the specification of the NSCs because
it wasn't very clear from the audience
whether b27 is actually necessary during
NSC generation or not
so b27 is not necessary for the matcher
early induction from PSCs to neural stem
cells so that's actually our neural
induction supplement so we provided
online on our website it comes as the
neural induction supplement plus our
neuro basal media so there's actually no
b27 and then that media combined for the
the length of the seven days will
transition those pscs to neural stem
cells okay thank you
so then speaking a bit more about the
NSCs themselves so we know that they're
most mostly of a hidin behind branch
phenotype but there's a couple questions
around how do you know that your NSC
specification actually worked well what
kind of markers can we use to make sure
it was successful yeah that's a great
question so we do do immunise on a
chemistry at the end of that day seven
so once you guys replate and I showed
you that that one million per well
replated that's a good time to do some
ICC staining so we recommend standing
for socks to pack six socks one and
nested which are all common neural stem
cell markers and then we also do provide
on our website a nice kit of all of
these
all of these antibodies combined along
with their secondary stands for you guys
for convenience so you can purchase that
and just aim your neural stem cells with
that kit and you'll have all your your
QC so along the same lines do you know
how efficient the conversion to NS C's
is for example have you looked at
whether there's any remaining
pluripotent stem cells in the NSC
culture so it is possible to get
remaining very potent stem cells in the
culture and this goes back to the
beginning of the lecture when I was
discussing the starting culture and how
mother how homogenous that should be so
if you have a modernist culture with
minimal to no differentiation in a
feeder free environment that should
successfully transmitted to almost a
hundred percent of neural induction so
as long as you have a good starting
culture
you should have success of about a
hundred percent all right thank you
so now moving on to maturing the NSCs
into neurons so there seems to be a
little bit of confusion still around
what is in the maturation medium so
could you maybe elaborate a little bit
more about what the maturation medium
contains yeah so our maturation medium
so let's just use classical b27 as an
example so we use our neuro basil basil
as the basil medium and then we spiked
it with our b27 supplement which is a
50x supplement and then you can't you
may or may not introduce the culture one
supplement that I was discussing so
that's that would be a hundred X and
then we like to add glutimax
supplement and then two hundred milli
molar ascorbic acid okay so could you
elaborate a little bit more about what
the purpose of the culture one
supplement is yeah so our culture one
supplement is a really nice supplement
if you want to force the cells into a
clean neuronal differentiation so a lot
of the time in a lot of homebrew media
systems we find that once you plate for
maturation those neural stem cells still
tend to linger and proliferate quite
fast in the media and then what you'll
get is a lot of cell phones in your in
your final in vitro neuronal cultures so
culture one eliminates the proliferation
at the of the NFC's at that first stage
so then the only cells in the culture
should be mature neurons all right and
then going further into these
supplements in the maturation medium we
have quite a few questions around the
difference between be 27 and be 27 plus
so could you maybe discuss a little bit
what the differences are if any and then
explain why would you use one over the
other that's a great question so the
differences in our be 27 and B 27 plus
supplement is our B 27 plus accelerates
neuronal growth quite a bit so it speeds
up neuronal maturation and it increases
neuronal survival so a lot of the time
in your culture once you replay for NSCs
you'll have our you'll we play the NFC's
into neuronal maturation you'll have
quite a bit of cell death and then the
remaining
we'll be there to grow this be 27 plus
we'll eliminate that self death a little
more and you'll have more neurons in
your cultures so you'll be able to make
less cultures and have more neurons and
then they also accelerate in maturity
and we base this off of a couple
different tests we have but some good
examples are accelerated inner eye out
growth which is accelerated compared to
our p27 media as well as competitors and
then also using multi electrode array we
have shown that it has spontaneous
activity and neural network activity
that's been increased compared to
competitors and b27
so that's just adding to the fact that
it's maturing faster ok Thank You Jordan
so there's a someone online here that is
still a little bit confused about the
difference between the induction medium
and the maturation medium so could you
please remind again on the key
differences between the two media
so our neural induction medium so that's
induction from pluripotent stem cells to
neural stem cells that includes our
neuro basal medium and our neural
induction supplement so you can buy this
package together on our website and then
the maturation medium is our same basal
medium neuro basal medium but it has our
be 27 or be 27 plus supplement our
culture one glutimax and ascorbic acid
so in in the in the neuro stem in the
neural induction medium is in it's an
induction supplement it's not be 27
supplement alright thank you
to kind of an end the train of the
differentiation steps we get have a few
questions about the neurons that you get
out at the end so could you speak a
little bit more about their electrical
activity and if you have any idea of
what kind of neurons are in those
cultures it would be great if you could
address that as well okay in using our
be 27 or be 27 plus culture systems we
tend to get a more high brain specific
but it is a mixed population of neurons
so we have Stanford glutamatergic as
well as GABAergic markers and we show
both so there's both excitatory and
inhibitory neurons in the in the culture
system um however it has been shown that
- if you use our neural induction media
to make neural stem cells you can target
using different media systems different
types of neurons so if you still want to
use our neural induction supplement to
create NSCs
and we've shown you can make
dopaminergic neurons out of them and
motor neurons out of them and a couple
other specific types of neurons so if
more hindbrain specific mix population
neurons isn't your goal you can still
use the neural induction kit to make
NSCs and specify to the direct
differentiation that you would like so
have you used these neurons in a high
content type environment where you're
using them for screening sorry have you
used the neurons in high content type
assays for screening yes so we have used
these neurons using our cell insight
which is our cell insight cx-5 and cf7
which are a high throughput imaging
systems so that these neurons are very
clear and they're very homogeneous and
they're spread out so our system
actually finds a cell body before it
finds axons and other other types of
stains depending on what what assay
you're running so because this
population is
very sparse in uniform they provide a
perfect thing for for high throughput
imaging Thank You Jordan
that was very informative I would also
like to thank our active online
participants and we hope to see you soon
at one of our other 24 hour of stem-cell
sessions thank you guys for listening
and I've had a great time answer your
questions about our be 27 and B 27 +
neuronal systems
you